Hello everybody and welcome to episode
number 20 of my 0 to 100 mil flipping
series. Can't believe we're on episode
number 20 already. Uh we're starting at
about
31 pretty much 31 mil. And yeah, this
rate we'll get to 100 mil at about 60
episodes, but I do not think it'll take
that long hopefully. And uh yeah, let's
get
started. Okay, so to start off, I think
we're going to do some ale of the gods
again. We're going to keep a little bit
of money to flip some other items, but
um we'll put offer in for somewhere
around 5,500k. Um the margin's still
about three or 400, so we'll do three of
these and find something else. So, next
up, I think we're going to try the Verox
armor set. Uh we flipped this once
before and it actually worked pretty
well. Um so, we're going to buy it for
1,800,000 coins. Um sorry, 18
1,800K and we're selling it for
1,650K. Um so, that is a 150k margin.
So, that's very good for the item. I
think the limit's somewhere around uh
eight eight to 10. I'm not really sure
exactly. Um we'll go ahead and buy um
eight of these probably. And yeah, we'll
come back when the stuff is sold. Okay,
so we are back. Um we did not buy any of
the ale of the gods really. Uh we did
get one. Sorry. But um mostly the Verox
sets were what we flipped. And uh we got
144k on each verac set and eight of
those I believe gives us over 1 mil. So
1.1 mil. Still a very nice flip. um the
ale of the gods. We only got one for
about 190k profit. Um so still pretty
decent and um yeah, let's continue on.
Okay, so we kind of have to run. Um so
unfortunately we're just going to put an
offer in for the of the gods. A little
boring. We've done it a bunch, but um I
don't know what works and we're going to
be gone for like a full day, so we might
as well uh leave it for a little while
and we'll come back when we are back.
Okay, so we are back. Um we managed to
buy and sell three A of the Gods. Uh, we
got about 210k in profit on each one,
giving us about 630k in total. Uh, which
is pretty decent. This item still works
pretty well. So, I still would recommend
it. Mind you, this is the second video
I've made kind of featuring it, so it
might not be so good going forward, but
you can see items like this do work.
Clue scroll items, master clue scroll
items. Um, you can make quite a bit of
money and not that much work really. I
just left that in for a day, came back,
600k profit. Boom. Um, but yeah, going
forward, I think we're going to try a
different item. So yeah, let's get
started. Okay, so the next set we're
going to try is the samurai set. Uh so
we'll start off by buying the greaves.
We're going to have to check the
margins. We haven't done this in a
while. So buying the greaves for
370k and we will sell them
for 200k. Well, that's a very good
margin.
270k 170k. Sorry, shitty maths going on
there. Um but yeah, we'll go put an
offer in for 20 of these for 205k. Next
up is the samurai gloves. uh wood offer
in and we're going to buy them for
429K and we'll put them in for 1GP and
see what we sell them for. It's going to
be 300k. So that's still a 130k margin
which is quite nice still. Um so I think
we can pretty much afford 20 of each of
the samurai pieces assuming they're good
to flip. So yeah, we'll go ahead and put
an offer in for roughly 300k, probably
like
305. And we'll do 20 and then move on to
the next item. So, I'm not really sure
if we're going to try this Samurai Casa,
which I guess is some sort of hat. Uh,
it's definitely much more expensive,
two, three times more, but uh, we'll
check it. Maybe it has like an insane
margin. Uh, so we bought it for
872K and we're going to sell it
for
837K. Okay. So, that's not that great
compared to the other
items. Yeah, I think we're just going to
skip that. Now we'll move on to the
boots. Uh so buy those for
400k and sorry for 28k is what we bought
them for. And we're going to sell them
for 185. Um I think we'll do those
still. That's definitely not as good,
but still very good relative to other
items. So we'll go ahead and do another
20 of those. And last up, I think we're
just going to do some more ale of the
gods. Um we have about enough for three
of them and we'll put an offer in
roughly around 5500
5600 and yeah we'll come back when we
have uh sold some of the stuff. Okay, we
are back and uh we've sold pretty much
everything we bought. Uh we're in the
process of buying a couple more of the
ale of the gods. But uh yeah, let's have
a quick look at this. Uh so the ale of
the gods, we got about 200k on each and
we bought two of those giving us a 400k
profit. So not too bad. The samurai
boots, we only got a 22k margin on them.
And we got 10 of those, giving us 220k,
so not too bad. But, uh, the samurai
greaves are where we made most of the
money. We got 155k on each one. And
seven of those gives us about
1,85k. So, over a mill, quite nice. And
the samurai gloves, we got about 200k
margin on each of those. And, uh, we got
three, which gives us about 624k.
Mind you, we did check the margin, so
about a quarter of that is pretty much
not true, but you know, whatever. I
don't feel like doing the math right
now. And yeah, pretty decent uh flip.
And yeah, we'll do a couple more of
these. Okay, so the Samurai Greaves has
a 60k margin in it, so pretty decent um
still. I mean, for how expensive the
item is. So, we'll go ahead and do 20 of
these and come back with a new item.
Okay, so let's check the samurai gloves.
Um, we're going to put them in for 500k
and we bought them for
494K. Actually quite close to that. And
then we'll see what we can sell them
for.
346K. So that's a 150k margin again. Uh,
so pretty good still. Um, the samurai
set is working quite nicely. So we'll go
ahead and put an offer in for the
samurai gloves. And we'll put in 20
again, I think. Yeah, we'll do 20. And
uh, we're going to check the samurai
boots again. Uh, see if we can get the
margin on that again. So, we're buying
them for
199K and we're selling them
for 175k. Um, so still pretty decent.
Um, I don't know. It's a little bit
slimmer though. I'm not sure if it's
actually going to be worth the time. I
think we might move on to another item.
Uh, we'll check the Verox set again,
actually, because it worked so well last
time. Uh, so we bought them for
1653K and we're selling them
for 1620k.
[Music]
Uh, I don't know. I don't know. It's not
really that
great. Okay. I think we're just going to
put a couple more ale of the gods in
actually. Um, put another in for 5500.
And yeah, we'll come back when some of
the stuff has bought. Okay. So, we are
back and we managed to sell the ale of
the gods um for a 200k profit on each,
giving us about 600k in total. And the
samurai greaves, we got a massive margin
on those. We got 272K on them, which is
insane. So, we got two of those giving
us 544K in profit. Still, this flip gave
us over 1 mil. So, we are breaking in
the cash. And this is where I'm going to
actually have to call it for today cuz
as I may have mentioned earlier, as
these flips take longer and longer to
do, while we're still getting a ton of
money, there's just less physical
footage because the flips take longer. I
have to wait longer for them to
complete. um they're quicker to edit the
videos which is nice. But um hope you
guys understand. If you would like um
leave a comment down below if you prefer
seeing a bunch of different flips
because I can move away from these
items, the slower ones that give me the
mount like larger profits, but I could
do some smaller items as well. Would you
prefer to see longer videos with a lot
more kind of smaller flips in between or
would you just is this good? you'd
rather watch a 5 minute condensed video
of me actually, I don't know, making
quite a bit of money, or would you
prefer to see smaller flips, bigger
flips, a bunch of them combined, maybe
longer videos, but you
would you would get more items, more
ideas, stuff like that. And anyway,
yeah, if you could leave a comment what
you would like, I'm either thinking
they're going to be six or seven minutes
going forward or what they have been in
the past at about 10 to 12. Anyway, long
exit. Hope you guys enjoyed the video
and I'll see you guys in episode number
21.
[Music]